right here with reaction to our opening
monologue House Majority Whip Steve
Scalise you may remember he was shot
going back a year ago and thank God he's
with us today and he's making a full
recovery and also Florida Attorney
General Pam Bondi let me go to your
incident you went to see the mr. Rogers
movie first mistake anti bullying about
tolerance all right each other's
differences here's the thing I want you
to tell people how bad this was cuz the
video didn't capture it right they're
calling you every name in the book right
you had your boyfriend with you right
and what did they say to him oh you can
say well we get there we're waiting in
line to get tickets and it's a
documentary about mr. Rogers and all of
a sudden this woman comes out of nowhere
and starts telling me that I'm ripping
babies out of women's arms and who does
that sound like the Peter Fonda about
Melania so they can't even come up with
their own lines and I said I'm glad
you're videoing me let me explain to you
I never agreed with separating the
mothers from the babies and I'm glad the
president the president the president
signed the executive order and I said
you know this is a congressional issue
they didn't even know who their
congressmen were so then when they
realized if that wasn't working just a
few in my face screaming at the top of
their lungs they were using the P word
the B word the effort was you know every
award imaginable come on aren't you
gonna protect her come on come on aren't
you a boyfriend it's trying to get him
over they call him blue eyes you're
gonna let us say this to your girlfriend
yeah he would have if he would have
responded and defended you he gets
arrested and that's that's how I stopped
him from defending me I said they want
to hurt you this is what they want and
there were two more altercations Shawn
after that and you after I thought they
were gone and they literally at one
point big big guys to surrounded you
blocked me from walking in why are you
not if somebody gets in your grille like
that is that not considered itself an
attack it's an assault it's an assault
if they block me from leaving but you
know what that's what they wanted they
wanted to be dragged out in handcuffs
they wanted the same I wasn't going to
give them the five boys
doing this to use Sara Sanders secretary
Nielsen right well you know and children
we're gonna go after Baron we're gonna
go after the four-year-old granddaughter
of the president Milani Ivanka really
the real tough guys I'm available come
after me
follow me I'll handle it well and that's
it and they didn't even know what they
were talking about so then they had two
hours while I was in the movie and and
they gathered more people reinforcements
they called him reinforcements they
Google you know all these things to say
and then that's the video that was shown
after the fact but you know the police
said we're gonna take you out the back
door and I said no way I'm walking out
the door that I came in they're not
going to bully me congressman first of
all great play at second base and I
think you had been in studio just before
the game I can't you were that was an
unbelievable play but you were in first
play of the game and I watched your
piece which the with my buddy Steve
Doocy
but here's the thing you got shot a year
ago and I know you don't have feeling
basically in one foot is that correct
yeah the left foot still has a lot of
nerve damage and you know I'm working on
that I do physical therapy three days a
week but you they sure helped me get a
lot better way to go question do you
connect there what do you saw with
secretary Neilson and what happened to
Sara what happened to Pam and the things
that are being said about blowing up a
White House and the things that are said
about Baron Trump and about the
president's granddaughter
do you think these words are igniting
something that's going to result in
somebody getting severely injured or
maybe even killed Sean clearly they are
insightful and and I've seen personally
how that kind of insightful language can
lead to something very dangerous and so
you know there there are fine lines to
cross we're a nation that was built on
this great idea that you can disagree
with people you can express your
disagreement but resorting to violence
he never says cory booker cross a line
by encouraging people to confront people
that like donald trump and gas stations
and restaurants confront them confront
them what are they trying to do here
except create a situation that's gonna
blow i think it crosses the
Shawn and again I mean this is about
civility you should go and want to win
your ideas in the in the debate of
public opinion if you can't if your
ideas are worse which frankly I think
conservative ideas win the day all the
time so then they go and try to resort
to name-calling and ultimately violence
and that's where I think it crosses the
line and so like a [ __ ] like today you
know what and god bless those two to
think that to Capitol Hill police
officers walked in a wide-open field
with pistols against the rifle that was
basically a death sentence but they did
it anyway that's how great they did it
anyway heroes heroes we all look the
miracles of God Shawn God performed real
miracles but we shouldn't get to this
and the left shouldn't talk we didn't
tolerate it under Obama you and I and so
many others didn't agree with his
policies but we never condone this kind
of action do you agree with me this is
all about they're losing they lost that
the president's successful that is
economic record foreign policy record
and the fact that motors which hunt
their great hope is crumbling is that
what's causing this and the election
pending I do I think people are so angry
that the president's succeeding that our
country is thriving that they're lashing
out in any way they can Shawn at the
expensive I can take care of myself
but at the expense of all these other
people it's what they cared about women
and children and had a monopoly of
compassion it's all crock and it's all a
big lie
and this is about politics and the
reason I ran the history lesson is do
they do it every two of four years it's
their only play ball right and
somebody's gonna get killed mark my
words
I pray to God I'm wrong but this is
getting scary thanks what you went
through you should not have gone through
I'm sorry mr. Scalise same thing
congressman same to you